شكل عام 2003 نقطه تحول في اقتحامات
المستوطنين اليهود للمسجد الاقصى المبارك
انذاك سمحت شرطه الاحتلال للمستوطنين
باقتحامه تحت حمايتها كامر واقع التقسيم
الزمني الذي تحاول اسرائيل فرضه يعني
تخصيص اوقات محدده لدخول المسلمين
واخرى خاصه باليهود باغتسان الساعه
والايام طوال العام
بموجبه بات على المسلمين افراغ المسجد
الاقصى لساعات محدده يوميا ليصلي اليهود
ثلاث صلوات في الاقصى
وتسعى اسرائيل الى تخصيص المسجد الاقصى
لليهود خلال اعيادهم التي تصل الى 100 يوم
وجميع ايام السبت
والتقسيم المكاني هو تخصيص مناطق وزوايا
معينه من المسجد الاقصى لكل من الطرفين
حيث تسعى الحكومه الاسرائيليه لاقتطاع
منطقتين ينظر الى محاولات اسرائيل لفرض
التقسيم الزمني والمكني كخرق للوضع
التاريخي القائم الذي سادى في فتره الدوله
العثمانيه ثم الانتداب البريطاني والحكم
الاردني وصولا الى بدايه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عام 67
وبموجبه فان الصلاه في المسجد تقتصر على
المسلمين وحدهم ويمكن لغير المسلمين
زيارته سياحا فقط
ولتنفيذ مخططاتها تعتمد اسرائيل على قانون
القوه
تعمد لابعاد المصلين لاشهر تمنع من هم دون
الاربعين من الصلاه في الاقصى تحضر ما
تسميه تنظيم المرابطين والمرابطات
وتعتدي على المعتكفين
[موسيقى]